this is a $600 footstep
[Music]
shoes are the only article clothing I
will spend significant money on I'll
spend like 80 to 100 bucks on a pair of
shoes if I really really like them I
usually just bend around a hundred
dollars in my shoes but that's it I
don't spend tons of money unlike any
clothing items once a shoe gets over
like 130 150 it's like it's not really
on my radar I don't really know too much
about shoes I wear boots that's pretty
much all I do know I have these yeah
yeah how would you pay for these okay
okay I can hang with these I do feel
like there's genius marketing to come up
with these barefoot based running shoes
because way less material not a strong
material and they can sell them for just
as much I would say like from my
experience this is probably $80 I was
gonna say $1 if you say 79
I will $79 I think these ones are like
$60 shoes 100 I literally have like five
pairs of these yeah I just can't
remember how much I paid for it but I
want to say solid like baby no honey I
feel like it's like 75 Wow Kevin was way
off you lost me yeah I don't know like
these are funky shoes oh it looks like a
boot and a sneaker yeah the same time
they look like mutated chucks these
almost remind me of Spinelli from recess
yeah these are very much like only a
cartoon character who is it's like a
converse on steroids yeah it's a
converse on steroids mixed with like a
bowling shoe oh I'm gonna save 120 Oh
200 125 160 135 bucks hundred the
what a thousand eighty five dollars for
these shoes do we have to pay that touch
them like this like is there like a ten
dollar touching fee
it looks like skater shoes from middle
school they're kind of like cool space
shoes they're very plain but they are
simultaneously and unique I've never
seen a shoe that looks like this before
after touching the other shoe I'm just
like oh I'm very confused on shoes on
they look like adidas at the top but
they just look like bricks like these
look heavier than air force one I'm
gonna say 175 just because you're paying
for that hike I'm gonna take a risk and
say 3165 I'm gonna say 225 50 bucks I'm
gonna have all these at about $300 jeez
you were high bomb that was a dad I
thought that I was gonna be over I would
not have the stones to make a pair of
shoes and be like yeah here they are
twirled that'll be $550 whoa this could
be like a 13 year old shoe these are
ugly I kind of like him this could be
like a lady Gaga shoe hosting I'm gonna
go out on a limb I'm gonna say that
these shoes are really expensive not
because it's flashy are you're also
getting a weapon the inside looks like a
luxury car
it also says Paris inside photoshoot all
right easily over $1,000 oh wait okay
these are all plastic and itching $45
I'm gonna say like five is it $65 I
think is it like to make the costume
jewelry
I'm gonna just hope that at least one of
these is cheap and call this 110 bucks
I'm gonna say these are eight hundred
dollars five thousand that's that's car
I'm gonna go lower would say five
hundred my tactic was slightly off just
by it by smidge I think that's how much
I paid for my my down payment on my car
these are the kind of shoes that you
only know are that expensive if you're a
sneakerhead like who are you trying to
impress with these shoes for me the joy
of buying anything is the value and the
value is how cool it is divided by the
price so I will never be proud of
something that is that expensive